welcome back to new rockstars this is a
big question this is a show where we
give you too much information about like
the confusing questions like how
powerful is everyone the Eternals are
coming into the universe how powerful
are they could they win an arm wrestling
match against Thanos we're gonna find
out he's Eric boss and I'm Phil Emily
and we're gonna answer this question for
you because yeah Thanos is out of the
picture now a Wanda Maximoff is the
psychopath who's taking over everything
and the Eternals are coming into the
picture so Phillip thank you hit me with
your big cue why don't you hit me with
that be good Eric Eric
if dannis is out I want to know not only
who I mean the the given right question
is who's gonna replace them but actually
who's powerful enough to be a high-level
threat that is theoretically scarier
than Thanos right we can't go back now
right so I want to know who but I want
to know specifically power levels and
then I think it's just fun to just kind
of like where does everybody fit on this
Power Rankings yeah everything well it's
been kind of a hard question to answer
over the years because the comics
constantly fluctuate who's beating who
spider-man struggles with a little baby
a baby a child but he doesn't wanna be a
daddy is the thing well you gotta be
careful they're very fragile yeah but
now he struggles to lift a little car in
the comics and then later he holds it
together a fairy yeah and so these
things are always changing based on the
situation because comics this is how it
works we know this well according to
marvel's official website they actually
do have a system for ranking everyone
and they rank characters according to
six categories durability energy
fighting skills intelligence speed and
strength and they rate each of those on
a scale from one to seven so you can
have a max combined total of 42 points
which is gotta be a Douglas Adams's yeah
yeah anytime you see anything's 42 it's
like it's not Jackie Robinson yeah it's
not Eric's true age oh now in a risk
category for that coronavirus okay well
we can actually compare this to what we
know about the MCU because these
characters have faced each other and
there is a certain logic to the MC
and thanks Kevin Feige has said about
who is the most powerful based off of
where they are and the endgame fight the
like main and game fight did a lot of
power ring oh yeah right people shifted
a lot just in that scene so I have
boiled these all down into five tiers
five like groups that we can kind of
clump people together and five tiers is
what I have for how many kills I've done
four out of five tiers worth it well the
first tier that I'm gonna talk about is
what I call the Terrans the earthbound
powerful people so we can just start by
asking who's the most powerful
earthbound hero that we know in the MCU
I think we should start with who I think
we should start every conversation with
the Hulk because he's fascinating yeah
he's ridiculous and he rises to meet the
strength needed he should yeah according
to comics Loren mythology Hulk
theoretically should be the most
powerful because he has kind of an
infinite power score because yeah he
meets whatever challenge he faces the
more he gets hit the angrier and bigger
and madder he gets and he should
theoretically be able to fight anyone so
long as they're fighting him with like
raw strength and punches as opposed to
palm strokes because that is the way to
any never bring anyone to anyone yo yeah
but the MCU changed this right so an
infinite worth a knows K owed him
without using any of the Infinity stones
which was a disruption to that logic and
currently he remains injured so even
though the Marvel category gives him a
score of 32 out of 42 I think he
definitely has people who are more
powerful than I mean that's 10 points is
at least loss from he has an arm swing
swing we were joking this is kind of
like the football injury report it's
like no no I saw him limping so I don't
know if you should kind of play it's
gonna play a next one which brings us to
the next powerful figure who's a Terran
Carol Danvers so in the MCU her power is
derived from the space stone she's
infinity stone powered but according to
Marvel she's scored at 29 out of 42
crepitus powers are a big deal 29 and
when she
goes like Super Saiyan I think they're
saying like normal dormant rather than
going binary and in the MCU they've kind
of like expanded her powers and haven't
clearly defined it she's gets her powers
from the white dwarf in the comics his
name is Peter Dinklage Erik uh and I
don't think the name is Dorf for that
anymore dork like Stephen Kevin door but
the thing about Carol Danvers is in that
final about battling Avengers in game
she definitely holds her own against
Thanos like she is going blow-for-blow
with him and she seems to be okay but
she does get Team Rocket blast off again
and gets punched out of the movie
so we it's not really clear how powerful
she is but she's she's up there I can go
blow-for-blow and get blasted off and I
feel weaker after every word he said
means something different than what you
think with that mouth you've got mental
so let's talk about Peter quill so
Marvel's website only gives him a score
of 17 out of 42 and in the movies yeah
Peter quill seems like kind of a dope
right he picks the wrong time to punch
someone out of a trance he almost ruined
everything
but the MCU also established him as the
son of a celestial right and he can hold
the power stone in his hand not many
people can hold an infinii stone in
their hand without like getting
disintegrated we're gonna address that a
little bit later to in a question
there's only been in the fireplace for
two hours so as the son of us will talk
about Celestials in a bit but like that
clearly making Peter quill a more
powerful character than he should be
yeah but I mean technically you
referenced the fact that he punches
Santos at the wrong time but you could
say he caused the entire snap killed
half him he's kind of an idiot but also
like he killed half the life of the
universe so he kind of but he also has a
skill that no one else has it's dance
fighting so pointless killer playlist
now there's a couple people I'm gonna
run through really quickly that are not
currently in the MCU but probably will
be soon villains like Kang the Conqueror
and Doctor Doom super-powerful kangas
twenty-seven Doctor Doom is thirty one
score Jean Grey not a villain until she
becomes dark Phoenix has a score of 24
out of 40 tubes she is the most powerful
mutant at least at this point in the
timeline apocalypse is is more powerful
than her according to history but all
these figures are potentially super
powerful and could be like in whatever
movie they are the most powerful thing
we've ever seen yet that brings us to
the character who Kevin Feige says is
currently or about to be the most
powerful figure in the MCU Scarlet Witch
yes Wanda Maximoff now Marvel's website
only gives her a score of 18 and to be
fair we haven't really seen her do much
yet but the girl is able to cure an
accent pretty effectively it's not
thank you for me seven five B's argument
is that she was able to almost bring
Thanos to his knees if not for his
raining fire from his ship she would
have had him in that moment and no one
else in that fight had him until Tony
Stark got all six Jim's in his hand she
can warp reality with her mind I think
that's what Kevin Feige saying there's
no one else can actually like change the
fabric of existence just with the power
of their mind so I think we're about to
see that in one division so that covers
the first tier of just like earthbound
heroes but let's move on to our second
tier the tier I've titled God's demons
and aliens
so we've met a lot of these people in
the MCU right and let's start with the
Asgardians Thor Thor actually has a
pretty high score borscht war is 32 out
of 42 he's a god of thunder
he's got the odinforce but he's also
really stupid
he emotionally eats he lets himself go
who we tell you my right now Thor but
the thing about Thor and all the
Asgardians I gotta lump them on the same
tier together
Loki Heimdall Valkyrie hello they're all
confined by the Ragnarok event so in the
Norse mythology all of Asgard comes
crumbling down again and again again
throughout history due to their
apocalyptic event
Ragnarok it's a cycle it repeats so
eventually whatever successes are
strength they reached Ragnar aughts come
in and it's gonna reset that limits
their power to a finite level think the
President of the United States there's a
term limit there you see another
character has been established in the MC
but we haven't seen him yet is Adam
warlock
so Adam warlock is basically like space
Jesus or Jesus or Jesus in the comics is
roughly on par with San Jose Jesus come
Bible that people hand you as you walk
around downtown LA he's roughly on par
with Thanos when he fights he has these
soldier and putting his head at one
point and any time he gets too injured
he can just like Rico Coonan hahaha see
in a couple weeks just like there the
cocoon think of it roughly I'm on the
same level of Adam warlock is a Silver
Surfer
he's a score of 36 out of 42 he's The
Herald of Galactus he can like absorb
attacks and if you remember that you
know rise the Silver Surfer a movie
they're like how do we beat him you got
to separate him from his board so
there's always like one thing that can
kind of limit these data other
their power is infinite same thing is
the coolest bully in middle school yeah
kick him off that bull that sweet board
gave him all his power
I have skateboarders all kind of like
know me and it's like Hitchcock's birds
whenever I see skateboarders like how I
used to try to wear vans and high school
and they made fun of me because I didn't
actually skate in my middle school kids
were would fight with skateboards like
they were these wheels are bad handles
now we're also not to meet the Eternals
and the leader the Eternals is Icarus
you're seeing a comic image right now it
looks real stupid and goofy but he's
gonna be played by freakin Robb Stark in
the movie they're like semi immortal you
know they the earth eternals are
essentially immortal they never really
aged so that's a big deal we're talking
about gods at this point so we're gonna
learn a lot more about them soon but
they they are outranked by some other
people but they're kind of like mid-tier
of all of our Power Rankings other
characters we've seen them see the
elders of the universe so we're talking
the collector we're talking the
Grandmaster they're brothers we think
from other mothers they're technically
not cosmic but their lives are infinite
in terms of length their power is
defined by whatever they're interested
in so if they're interested in
collecting all these like cosmic gems
and things they could potentially get
super cosmic level powerful or if
they're just interested in being like a
gladiator arena judge that's as powerful
as they're gonna get but technically
Jeff Goldblum's Grandmaster is more
powerful at 32 points than collector at
22 points oh that's a big difference a
big difference but it's more of a comic
score now another character along with
the mutants coming in apocalypse so
apocalypse is the original mutant super
powerful 41 out of 42 points
he was the like og mutant created by the
Celestials in ancient times all of
mutant kind originated from him and he's
like the inspiration of all of our earth
gods like it's imply that the Old
Testament was based on a story of
apocalypse he helped the Egyptians build
their pyramids he helped the chosen
people find their way to the chosen land
but he's like he's a pretty bad guy yeah
and he has another one these people if
he comes into a movie it's gonna be a
big problem for everybody and then it
brings us to our man mr. Thanos now
thanos says a score of 36 out of 42 but
the thing about Thanos is he is an
eternal he has a deviant gene but he's
an eternal so he kind of has that semi
immortality but he's the one character
we know of at least an MCU to gather all
six Infinity stones and do something
with them not only like Tony Stark wears
the gauntlet Hulk wears the gauntlet
other people carry it but this guy knows
how to sew at his peak this guy reached
cosmic level abilities in the Infinity
Gauntlet comics when he gets the stones
he snaps and all the other cosmic
entities who were technically more
powerful than him the Galactus all these
other folks they go complain to the
Living Tribunal and the Living Tribunal
rules in his favor
so he's above them when he gets all the
stones so they know says among all these
other gods demons and aliens in the
second tier the most powerful when he
has Wayne E as the stone so now we're
moving into the third tier what I call
cosmic entities but am I tangible so
like you can kind of touch them but like
what's on you now what is this it's
hands eyes are you oh good good because
I'm in age bracket and be recovered
can't find this stuff okay so let's talk
about Dormammu we saw him in the first
Doctor Strange movie he's the ruler of
the Dark Dimension and he cannot really
be defeated he can just kind of be
pissed on aggravated by being stuck in a
time loop he's essentially Bill Murray
in Groundhog Day if you're Bill Murray
what I mean is as powerful as you
consider him to be that's what Dormammu
is basically cannot be killed
nightmares kind of on the same level he
might be the villain in the second
Doctor Strange movies a ruler the dream
dimension he's kind of like this
nightmarish dream a monster to mommy
let's a score of 38 nightmares a score
of 34 we have met a couple Celestials
you go to living planet and the MCU is
defined as a celestial he has the power
score of 36 out of 42 we also saw who
was later to find it's east on the
searcher in the collectors story he's a
celestial so the Celestials are like the
gods of the gods
they created the eternal
there was like kind of their genetic
experiments and trying to create life in
their own image on earth they got the
Eternals so you gotta imagine they got
to be of above the Eternals tier and
they haven't been implied to at one
point wield the stones and eons past so
yeah they're up there in this third tier
alongside them is the first 42 out of 42
we're gonna talk about here Phoenix
force so this is the force that goes
into Jean Grey Phoenix force identifies
Jean Grey is the first like worthy
mutant to attach to one that can like
withstand having this Phoenix force
inside of her and Phoenix force has been
described as a child of the universe
some people say the Phoenix force
predates the Big Bang like was born out
of a reborn out of the fires of the Big
Bang and just kind of like a zips around
the universe doesn't really process time
the same way we do and doesn't really
think the way humanity does like Tommy
just like Tommy is Tommy Phoenix force
question mark big question big question
and then finally another 42 out of 42
Galactus so Galactus is the other person
on our screen here interesting
so the khalaqtu siz is kind of crazy
right a giant cosmic entity big dumb
antler helmet but Galactus arguably
keeps the universe in balance by feeding
off the energy of dying or dead planets
but he's not like thoughtless he feels
guilt when he does it like he has a
personality so he's not completely
abstract he can be like hit he can be
punched but most people can't really
beat him he's roughly on par with Thanos
when Danice gets all six of the stones
that's what Galactus is but I don't know
I I feel like a true God should not feel
things yeah I was guilty I feel like
that numbers fudged a little like they
just want Galactus to feel like a 4242
but it feels like he doesn't do anything
to earn it like why do you need a Herald
bin to tell people then you're about to
come eat their planets loser Galactus is
gonna eat me in my sleep yeah like
that's how you wake up you're beaming
but this is my succubus
so now we're in the fourth tier and
things are getting pretty abstract here
because now we're just talking about
like these cosmic entities that
represent ideas but they're defined in
the Marvel Universe so we're talking
about things like mistress loves sire
hate master order and Lord chaos they're
kind of like other sides of the same
coin these kind of opposing ideals but
they have like these entities that
represent them in the cosmos until
American Philip are up there and that's
kind of great but all these things are
just kind of like we need a personality
to represent this thing that affects our
lives kind of like the stones represent
these other laws of the universe and
that brings us to the Watchers so the
watchers are true God figures watching
the watcher is a score of 33 out of 42
but it's only because he doesn't really
fight they oversee they observe they
record everything in the universe but
usually they don't intervene the
exception is watching the watcher
actually warned the Fantastic Four that
Silver Surfer was coming so that was one
moment the Watchers intervened but in
the MCU Jeffrey Wright has been cast as
who watches the watcher kind of the
Cryptkeeper figure of this anthology
what if series so it's just funny that
the most powerful established character
in the MCU is like this crypt keeper's
gonna set up this next story with Peggy
Carter did the Super Soldier Serum I'm
more powerful than everyone I used to
think that the Crypt Keeper knew Elvira
and I like like that would be like we're
like dating or something
yeah I also I didn't know the concept
that like a dead body over time like the
hair keeps growing so I definitely
thought crypt keeper was a lady for a
long time you know I can't recruit
keeper being like Elvira's gay friend
and they like they go to Knott's Berry
Farm and like make fun of the characters
and the Legman virus still looks good
that looks great they should be the dark
universe they're fantastic
my goal in life is to be the Crypt
Keeper and of all this it's like four
years away so the final of this tier
four is eternity so this is one of these
like Oh Doctor Strange just too much
acid and he's got to talk to the
universe now eternity cr.42 out of 40 to
eternity is the embodiment of existence
itself you've seen in the comics it's
just kind of like this outline this
cloaked outline that has the planets and
stars floating around inside of it the
thing about eternity is some people say
in guardians the galaxy vol 2 I
moment Peter quill looks up and he's
like and he kind of like that same
cosmic stuff swirling around his eyes as
we were saying in that moment
he's communing with the character of
eternity but the problem with eternity
is it's still bound by the universe
itself so when the universe ends
eternity ends there are there's a fifth
final tear that is above even the ice
that's tier 5 what I call the meta
cosmic entities they're above everything
there's two people here The Living
Tribunal kind of the Supreme Court
Justin the Chief Justice of the Marvel
Supreme Court has final say over all
conflicts doesn't really intervene just
kind of like weighs in on smaller
conflicts so there's that whole
courtroom scene from the Infinity
violence room and we talked about and
actually the writers of these movies
said that they were going to feature a
cameo of the Living Tribunal in that
wizard duel sequence between Thanos and
Doctor Strange on Titan they were gonna
have like a trial scene where they met
with the Living Tribunal so in a way
it's kind of an headcanon of the MCU I
mean they keep referencing it and they
have the staff of the living trail right
in the Doctor Strange movies and then
finally the most powerful figure from
all of Marvel Comics in the Marvel
Universe is the figure who is called the
one above all so the score of this
person is undefined unknown but the one
above all it's just kind of this
interesting quirky figure it takes
multiple forms depending on the scene
often he's depicted as a bartender and
this fulcrum lore or hasn't it been
Jack Kirby and then Jack Kirby and the
Fantastic Four comics they they go to
like a realm further beyond and and he
just they're in an artist studio and
Jack Kirby is the one above all so in
the MCU that could be Stan Lee that
could be Kevin Feige there is some kind
of like meta figures outside of all this
so that it's kind of our breakdown of
all the powerful figures we know of in
the MCU who of that list is most likely
to be next because it feels like you
don't want to go 242 out of 42
definitely not and that's why people are
saying Galactus is coming there's still
room to work our way up
we know Adam warlock is coming in the
next in the next guardians of the galaxy
movie I've made some arguments that Kang
a conqueror
could come into the Loki series it's
kind of like the ultimate time-traveling
villain the guy who knows more about
timelines than anyone else and nightmare
it seems to be coming up in Doctor
strange - so we're starting to work our
way up this cosmic scale but the thing
is is the whole point of this is it's
such a wide spectrum of power and you
have to kind of work your way up to it
yeah there's this version of Superman
that I'm obsessed with like it just it
doesn't make sense like it's too - just
jump - it just doesn't work yeah I
thought it'd be fun to look at some of
the weakest ones - so do you ask like
Uncle Ben is pretty weak because Uncle
Ben he's the djoko's local band is
always dead in comics right yeah sucks
fight anyone but Phillip I think we
consider ourselves part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe right it's our home
universe absolutely like to spend all of
our thoughts in time I think we should
rank ourselves so there are these six
categories durability energy fighting
skill to drink I think we should rate
each other on a scale of one to seven
for each of these categories and see
what our scores are great let's do it
six and a half hours native and we're
back after drunkenly assessing each
other and potentially I'm not gonna hurt
your feelings you're gonna hurt mine no
I don't plan to but you know offenses
inaudible okay so you're gonna hurt my
feelings okay so on durability Phillip
out of seven I rate you a two in here -
whoo seven I could have rated b12
because I imagined durability as like a
survivor man make it an affray type
thing and I just can't imagine you in a
outdoorsy scenario where like a plane
has crashed and you have to build a
campfire what my favorite book in sixth
grade was hatchet it was my only book I
read any read books
no durable person can read okay fine I'm
gonna give you your durability it is for
thank you because I was thinking to
myself how long we did shows together we
had to wear a lot of prosthetics on your
face for my face and and on your head
and those shows were so long but you
would have had higher but you have
really bad alcohol tolerance and I think
you got graphite poisoning when I poked
you with those pencils recently and
you've been complaining about it ever
since
so you're not super durable but better
than two the pain has only grown okay on
the energy I rate you a four
I think you're right the middle row
because I think you have more energy
than I do I would rate myself lower than
a four but behind-the-scenes thing for
people watching every episode of proko
theory begins with Philip having to
scream to get excited to rip up energy
get Tommy to wake up every single time
there's even an edit where you hear me
say Tommy wake up because I'm wearing he
fell asleep because that happens but you
do it on episodes when Tommy isn't even
hosting so that one's for you okay
welcome to new rock star this is rogue
theory I have to go super saiyan your
energy level again I was nicer I give
you a five I said that it was high it's
pretty high actually considering you
never ever sleep you sleep terrible
hours and you're up all night but then
you come in and you do your work all day
but then I also said that your max
energy level is only two points higher
than your minimum energy level you like
I've never actually seen you have a lot
of energy you just don't run out of the
very little that you can serve you're
like a roach and hibernation okay it's
balanced out the niceness is built on
fighting skills I ready to do it -
because I've kicked her ass twice on
camera so I feel like I have to rate you
- I roll the clips I was gonna give you
like a two but then I realized in
non-traditional fighting skills you once
blackmailed a candidate for student body
president
you threatened poor people on behalf of
the state of Florida I won't do that
again
and you are ruthless you stole a girl's
sweater and you lied about it for years
as a blazer you catfished your own job I
did my own job oh yeah but not this job
not this job yeah yeah and then we can
cut this but you you secretly dated my
ex-girlfriend and you didn't tell me for
a really long time
we gotta keep your ruthless good stories
my point your because it makes you look
like a hot dog willing to do whatever it
takes
you're ruthless and so your fighting
skills I rate it as a six wow that's
very generous considering how weak I am
Philip on intelligence i rated you a six
because i think your intelligence is
like you're your biggest strength I
would have given you a seven but like
you'd be compared to like Reed Richards
and Tony Stark and I feel
and either of us were seven on
intelligence we would not be working for
YouTube would be working for the NASA or
SpaceX or something yeah Vimeo I gave
you six as well I said you have high
intelligence you're one of the smartest
people I know but also I know you've
been scammed easily and I I know you
accidentally fed the same dog chocolate
brownies twice we have to cut it was it
was an accident though I do know that I
said but the fact that it happened
immediately again after it's like that
guy's not a seven he's not Reed Richards
um for speed cutting max speed I give
you a four middle the road I just I I
feel like I've seen you run very fast
but not like you're definitely faster
than I am speed I am what AM what am i I
gave you a seven no I am so slow well
you talk about other types of speaking
about how quickly you perform it's see
how quickly you put off videos oh and
write your scripts and sexual
performance okay that's the the scripts
and video that I'm referring to because
famously I move at a glacial pace
conserve that cockroach energy and then
for strength I give you a five I think
you're obviously speaks for itself like
I can lift in here I give you a - yeah I
said you and now i okay so phillips
grand total is 23 out of 42 which it's
pretty good it's higher than a Wanda
Maximoff 30 well I want to read your
rate actually I don't want to read your
ratings but I know you're gonna do it
anyway in the comments below and where
do you think Phillip and I belong in the
Marvel Universe we're the ones that
posted the spider-man footage yes
speaking of my wireless connection
Phillip you said you would yeah hey
Phillip are you tired of big wireless
taken advantage of I am I specifically
I've had big wire
for many years and they I'm paying $200
a month ooh I know I feel I have had the
Dwyer list holding me by the ankles
shaking me for change for the past
decade of my life I'm tired of it
bullies did to you yeah the bullies were
also good wireless yeah did wireless
well here's the deal folks mint mobile
is a great solution and thank you to
mobile for sponsoring this episode of
big question seriously thank you very
much yeah MIT mobile can help save you
more than a thousand dollars a year on
your wireless bill there's a better way
to get wireless and it's mint mobile
people it can be almost 10 times cheaper
than these other companies 10 times 10
times cheaper that's insane
and it's like the exact same thing it's
not like like the worst performance you
can make your calls you can be on the
internet whatever you can check my
social media right now to see how my
most recent Instagram post is doing
which is not as well as I'd hoped
yeah but I can check in at the same
speed but the point is you tell the
difference that's right mint mobile is
such a heroic wireless company that Ryan
Reynolds himself is a part owner
if Deadpool and detective Pikachu thinks
it's cool folks I feel like we should -
that's cool
he's so cool now - get your new wireless
plan for just 15 bucks a month and get
that plan shipped your horror for free
just go to MIT mobile.com slash big Q
mid mobile comm slash big Q a new
wireless LAN $15 a month I swear to god
I'm no longer I just kept saying yes
every time they're like we have a new
promotion where it's a little more
expensive
well now say yes to MIT mobile so that
they can help save your life I'll say
yes to some bite-sized questions all
right Philip we have a couple bite-sized
questions first from Chris Parrish he
wants to know how much would cap have to
drink to get legally drunk it reminds us
how in the First Avenger cap says it's
hard to get drunk because of a super
metabolism I'm super excited to answer
this question because it actually has an
answer that we can get and I love when
we have definitive answers so Pat drunk
you said legally drunk I'm gonna get
back to that okay but Ken cap even get
drunk okay our bodies metabolize you and
me we metabolize alcohol point oh one
six percent per hour so if you think of
your blood alcohol
you just can subtract 0.016 Oh every
hour and that's how how fast you start
coming back from it with your Liberty
metabolism but we actually have his
metabolism rate because Peggy tells us
in that scene his metabolism is four
times faster than the average person
so his point oh six 4% per hour now you
can already see the legal limit is 0.08
so he's almost doing that whole thing in
an hour pretty quickly but it also is it
insane it's not like he absolutely can't
get drunk but it's hard most people
perceive drunken feelings at 0.12% which
is significantly higher than the legal
limit for driving yeah why if you feel
drunk you very much yeah sit down in a
car turn the keys no drive into a school
the issue here isn't that whether or not
he can get drunk it's he has to outpace
his own metabolism in order to feel it
so he has to drink faster than he burns
it and the thing is you might think well
maybe his absorption rate we can't know
that it might be faster because he's
super him I don't I'm gonna give him the
absorption rate of the normal man
because if he had super fast absorption
he would die from poison like really
quickly could be better
so it's assumed he absorbs as fast as we
do he just burns it a lot faster so that
means we can use Chris Evans body stats
which I got all of them yeah and some of
them will surprise you and some of them
will impress you and some of them will
make doctors hate you our articles are
written about by Chris Evans body I
measured it I got these stats to figure
out how quickly alcohol hits his blood
and then I used Captain America's
metabolism rate for how quickly it would
burn it away so if he does three shots
per hour his not only will he'd not get
drunk he won't even get anything he will
be burning it faster than he's taking it
in it's only at four shots per hour that
he even starts to increase his blood
alcohol level but literally anything
point oh-o-oh 1% right it would take him
four shots an hour to even start the
climb yeah so that's very far from drunk
so for him to feel drunk he has to do
this is my best advice Captain America
in order for you to ever feel drunk
you're gonna need to do right away as
soon as you start drinking nine shots of
liquor
out of the gate then that's at the top
of the hour by the end of the hour you
will feel drunk for nine minutes nine
glorious minutes where anything goes
anything can be yours any surface as a
road no stop is suggesting that people
do that okay and on that tenth minute he
will no longer feel drunk so in order to
stay drunk if you're trying to have a
night of it it's a birthday then you
have to keep doing another shot about
every ten minutes once so you start with
the nine shots just to get up there and
now you've outpaced enough that you'll
feel drunk and then every time - you
have to do one more shot so that's a
nightmare and he's never gonna do that
some I have two other tips asgardian
beer
it exists in your reality it Thor has
claimed that it's much better than ours
I'm sure if it can make an ex Guardian
drunk you should drink that or
technically according to my math Jessica
Jones also has a right whole bottle at a
time that they actually can keep up with
that's expensive just pour it up your
butthole pour it in the booty hole up
your butthole
yeah I'm not tipping upside-down this
body don't tip you got to put it in
there and then you got to blow because
you need a vacuum effect yeah just got
to reverse the polarity of my digestive
system and then when I this is gonna
work hold on you have to suck it like
and then go and blow yeah exactly see
that worked and I'm real drunk now oh
man discuss next question from James
Jones asks if the tesseract melted
through the metal of an advanced Hydra
aircraft how was the Happy Days lunchbox
able to hold it good question actually
I've seen this one before a lot of
people think it's a plot hole I actually
identified a trend of when the tesseract
burns through things so through the
Hydra ship but also it burns Nick Fury's
hand once mmm you'll remember the
tesseract is a container for a
finiti stone that's right it is not the
Infinity stone it's so and even though
there's kind of some special properties
there where it has some sentience and
that's why I rejected Red Skull it
doesn't actually do this super heating
thing just on its own it has to have
recently been used so
look at the two times that it has melted
or burned someone it's because it was in
use on the space stone level but you can
think of the tesseract is almost like
paper towels holding a baking pan of
brownies it's fine on the way into the
oven it gonna hurt on the way out the
paper towels are still radioactive yes
that's exactly what I meant I saw
Chernobyl all right and our third
bite-sized question when Loki and Thor
get knocked to sack are in the by for us
by hella Loki says he got there weeks
before Thor for Thor so is there a
Bifrost time travel and is it connected
to the tesseract and Loki's series time
variants authority from miles miles this
was a really interesting question to
react to so the Bifrost is traveling
across space and time in a literal way
but actually is not traveling through
time and I like time-bending way it did
kind of seem like that in that moment
but what actually is happening is it's
not about the Bifrost at all it's about
Sekar it's about where Loki has gone
Sekar has weird time abilities of some
sort it seems to exist in some sort of
bubble or something so the Grand Master
says it pretty clearly says I would be
considered billions of years old we
talked about him earlier he's this
ancient but on Sekar he doesn't seem so
and it's as if he doesn't continue to
age on on Sekar Valkyrie has also been
there for 200 years and you know we
theoretically she hasn't aged I mean she
still look good touch Thompson so Loki I
haz thinks he's been there for Ted two
weeks or so he theoretically has inside
of Sekar it does have that that feel of
remember in interstellar the closer they
got to the black hole oh yeah there was
time distortion the double bonus is
right over there it's yeah - Wow now
here's a really interesting thing though
you kind of spun off a little Theory
here that I was thinking Hulk has been
there as the champion for some amount of
time we interpreted it after he left
earth on that ship that you know he ends
up on Sekar and then over that time you
know he whatever he becomes a champion
but he actually could have been there
for decades holy Sh for all we know
which would make a lot of sense for
about two things one that he is the
level of champion that he is everybody
is nuts everybody knows him everybody
has health merch on
but it could be this has been their guy
for four decades hundreds of years who
knows how long but also it could explain
why there's this sudden extreme rift
between Hulk and Bruce Banner where one
Bruce Banner finally comes back out Hulk
has actually not just been the frontman
of the body for weeks or months it could
have been years that Hulk has been
thriving you know doing some other stuff
the Hulk doesn't normally get to do and
then he got forced back in so maybe that
is partially also why oh now you want me
to come out again just to fight this guy
meanwhile I just spent you know a
hundred years yeah pillaging and
villages and the pillage people hey
thank you for those bite-sized questions
we have time for one mailbag question
from our mailbag Oh my mailbag is an
anatomical alright so this question asks
have you ever encountered a good ghost
or any supernatural phenomenon if you
like you have a ghost or I do well I
kind of I four years of my life did not
believe in ghosts I still kind of don't
but my new apartment has a ghost in it
and we've named him Dorian the door
ghost because our our bedroom door just
closes on its own even when there's not
a shift in air pressure it's not like
the the air is coming on or anyone's
passing it it's it's been open for ever
and ever for like an hour and then
suddenly it'll just close and here's my
theory on it so an apartment I used to
live in years ago burned down oh yeah
and sorry about that
thanks especially since you lit the
match I mean yes sorry um but my bedroom
had a lot of stuff didn't burn in it
because the door was closed and the
firefighters said this is we always tell
people close your doors when you go to
bed when you leave because that would
prevent the fire from spreading or at
least it'll slow it down or it'll be a
big surprise for whoever opens the door
so I always thought Dorian was the ghost
that's following me around maybe an
alternate version of myself who was home
when the fire happened who died and is
now following me in this dimension
closing the door to keep me safe
interesting
Dorian he's my Dorian Gray he dies while
yeah I also have been to this new home
of yours and it is pretty tilted so I'm
just goes no it looks like it's like
falling over at all times okay there's a
separate ghost a big guy goes and he
leans on it to go in he's sleeping fatso
yeah and the whole house gets knocked
over and then Dorian says by the way it
also closes door yeah don't get me
started on Marie she's my mom apartment
two wait I wish she was ago the only
thing that comes to mind for
Supernatural I was really sick in the
middle of watching Inside Man at the
theater an Inside Man starts with the
middle of the movie and then it like
starts over and then at the midpoint of
the movie you're back at the middle and
I kept thinking to myself oh think I
just can end
I want this movie to end because I'm so
sick and I was shaking at a fever and I
was there got on a date actually and she
was like completely ignoring me say I
want to watch mos def it's like I went
to movie end I want a movie to end and
then the celluloid melted while I was
having that thought and that's it we had
to leave and I got to go home and you
know feel better but that actually is
not the scary instance there's one that
I like I get scared to even talk about
cuz that was was exciting but it
reminded me in sixth grade summer I had
to go to summer school cuz we couldn't
afford to take care of babysitter's so I
was just going to summer school for no
reason and so I didn't even need to be
there but I was all day just in this
math class it was like a full day long
math class and the teacher was so mean
it's just this guy and he just like
would just like love to like make fun of
his students and it wasn't camaraderie
it was just mean I thought adults
exactly and if there's sixth graders I
about to be 7th but my birthday's in
July so come on so he so it's nearing
the end of the school day and we're just
like wrapping up our assignment and I
put my pencil down on the desk and the
girl in front of me happens to just
write then like like relax back she's
all done and my pencil goes right into
my hand jams in and you can see the scar
still if you can confirm for our viewers
that line there's a star
yeah and and you didn't know about this
car before direct and you and I have
never met no great
so that scars from it just like shoving
off straight line back and just like
ripping this open and so I like it was
now probably in shock because it was so
bad and it was bleeding a lot so I kind
of just like one like this and I stood
up and I walked to his desk I said um I
think I should probably go to the nurse
or something and he goes a little baby
gon cry and I was like yeah no I mean I
probably was going to cry but I at that
moment I wasn't crying and I go no and
he's like so my you got to go to the
nurse it's like my hand is bleeding a
lot it's curl but and he's like so you
are a baby so I sat back down I didn't
go to the nurse I just had my hand there
and then that night I was so mad and I
was a tell my mom I was think this guy's
anything I might call it a friend who
was like on vacation someone there like
leave me alone and I was like but I hate
this guy ate him so much I hate him so
much and he died that night he had a
stroke that night we come in the next
morning and we're it's 15 minutes after
after the bell and we're all just
sitting there waiting and then the
principal comes in and says your teacher
died last night he had a stroke and I'm
so sorry we're trying to find you a
substitute now my god and I just sat
there and I can do this to other people
I've never I've never had that kind of
thought about anyone else just in case
well you don't know what's gonna happen
in your future Phillip this is like a
Stephen King short story like a really
mean evil adult like it's killed because
the kid manifests it wills it I was like
no but the thing is I can't even go
along with this joke cuz I can't feel
that guilt
well guys this is cooking episode a big
question tell us your favorite Marvel
series about Eric at me and how fun
cartoons are but he died for real every
week of this show gets darker and more
terrified because I we're learning a lot
about each other and I Bret but in
selecting this question from the box
pour one out her the teach
Oh God Monsieur teach you are my
favorite well if you're not already at
your therapists office comment down
below with who you think is the most
powerful Marvel character is my my
points go up I think you're Max Evans
now the 4242 damn right
comment down below with your favorite
part of this episode and make sure to
follow us at @e a boss at building lean
on social media followed me rock stars
that to rock star mad at you and you can
get audio versions of this podcast early
if you just follow new rocks there's big
question wherever you get your podcast
and yeah we'll see you next week make
sure to hit us up with your big
questions using the hashtag big
questions just real quick also share the
show with your friends you feel like
it's a good entry point into new rock
stars so if your friend is kind of nerdy
and trying to find a way in give them an
all big question link see ya
see you next week
[Music]